a pesar de un presupuesto cada vez más
apretado muchos franceses siguen
haciendo donaciones al banco de
alimentos esta señora ya preparó varios
artículos estamos todos impactados con
inflación y todo lo que está pasando
Pero bueno si podemos ayudar con lo
mínimo aunque no sea mucho Hay que
hacerlo
para la colecta anual los voluntarios
del banco alimentario se enfocan en los
productos higiénicos y la comida para
bebés pero cada uno puede donar según
sus recursos
dos paquetes de pasta frijoles
comida para bebés compota y toallas
húmedas pienso que hay que pensar en los
demás estamos en un periodo difícil para
todo el mundo pero pienso que es
importante ayudar al prójimo todavía
puedo hacerlo entonces creo que es
normal participar en esta colecta Hola
Discúlpeme quiere participar en el banco
alimentario desde el viernes mil
voluntarios están repartidos en los
supermercados del departamento del bar y
a veces tienen bellas sorpresas
cada año hay un señor que muy
discretamente nos trae un carrito lleno
y un año nos explicó que en un momento
de su vida había necesitado el banco
alimentario y recibir ayuda ahora es su
turno de ayudar
en este hogar todas las donaciones están
centralizadas y organizadas después de
estar distribuidas a asociaciones el año
pasado en este mismo departamento 150
toneladas habían sido recolectadas una
colecta aún más importante ahora que las
necesidades aumentan en Francia la
escasez de ayuda alimentaria ha
aumentado un 15% en un año